cinquante bloc à gravir à réaliser les
pratiquants seniors de blogs s'étaient
donné rendez-vous ce week-end à montigny
le bretonneux des adhérents du groupe
verticale arc et des passionnés suis pas
au max mais ça va et les poissons sympa
non mais ce qui compte ici depuis deux
ans et que je participe à toutes les
compétitions qui fouet
c'est dur non là j'étais pas pas
forcément prêts à voir cette difficulté
là après je rame que depuis quatre mois
mais je m'attendais à pouvoir sortir des
blocs un peu plus un peu plus dur c'est
un esprit composition très très
développé et j'aime ça le dépassement de
soi la motivation
l'entraînement qui est toujours dur et
puis la réussite des fois aussi la
compétition surtout sept niveaux de
difficulté des novices aux experts près
de 200 personnes se sont confrontés au
deuxième quart d'heure boulder stronger
un contexte initiée par la salle
verticale arbres de montigny le
bretonneux des passages des problèmes à
réaliser dans une salle d'escaladé
succès des parcours d'escaladé qui
culmine à 4 mètres de haut une corneau
on enlève toute la partie harnais
baudrier d'escaladé rage du short
chaussons d'escaladé et l'objectif est
d'arriver par un chef d'entreprise 2000
euros de lots ont été répartis entre les
différents vainqueurs une troisième
édition est déjà en train de se préparer